DANIEL WILSON:
Three billion people
rely on wood, charcoal,
or other kinds of biomass
to cook their food.
And that kills three to four
million people every year.
INTERVIEWER: And this
is just because they
are inhaling all of that smoke?
DANIEL WILSON: It's as if you
were barbecuing, but right
there in your kitchen.
INTERVIEWER: Danny Wilson
is a development engineer
who's trying to tackle the
global health crisis that's
linked to cooking on
traditional cook stoves.
Almost half the
planet's population
has no choice but to use these
inefficient burners every day,
even though they're
putting themselves
and their families at risk.
When I traveled to rural
Tanzania last year,
I met Wanadi, who told
me how using a cookstove
affects her and
her grandchildren.
WANADI: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERVIEWER: Does that create a
lot of smoke inside the house?
WANADI: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERVIEWER: Sometimes you
cry because of the smoke?
WANADI: [NON-ENGLISH]
INTERVIEWER: What Wanadi
and her family experience
are the effects caused
by particulates,
fine particles composed
of toxic compounds.
These particles are found
in high concentrations
in smoke generated from
traditional cookstoves,
and if inhaled on
a regular basis,
they can cause a whole spectrum
of illnesses, including stroke,
lung cancer, and heart disease.
As Wanadi was cooking, you
could hear her coughing,
and her grandchildren
coughing around her.
And as she explained,
she has no other choice
but to cook this
way, even though she
knows that it can cause harmful
long term health issues.
What's incredible is that smoke
inhalation kills more people
worldwide than HIV
and malaria combined.
To combat this
global health crisis,
Danny and his team at the
Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratory have been working
on improving cookstove designs.
DANIEL WILSON: The cook stoves
are designed to really satisfy
two important needs for people.
One is to reduce
the amount of fuel
that people have to
burn to cook their food.
And then the second objective
is to reduce the amount of smoke
that people are exposed to.
INTERVIEWER: The team
based their initial designs
on the needs of
internally-displaced people
in Darfur, Sudan.
Here, wood is in scarce
supply, meaning women
often have to walk for hours
in search of sources of fuel.
DANIEL WILSON: When your life
centers around a seven-hour
walk to go get wood
and bring it back home,
it's very hard to make
space for education,
or business, entrepreneurship,
time and energy invested
in kids, et cetera.
So this problem is not
only a health crisis,
it's also economic crisis.
And I think of it as
a crisis of drudgery.
INTERVIEWER: The team came up
with the Berkeley Darfur stove,
an inexpensive, high efficiency
wood burning stove that
reduces fuel use by 50%.
Around 40,000 of
these stoves have
been distributed in
Sudan and Ethiopia,
and Danny and his colleagues are
constantly testing, updating,
and improving the design,
thanks to the input
of the women who use it, and the
data that Danny collects using
a specially-designed sensor.
DANIEL WILSON: Sensors give us
real-time, high quality data
about how the decisions
I'm making as a designer
are impacting the
adoption of those products
out there in the field.
INTERVIEWER: The challenge
for Danny and the team
now is to adapt and refine
their cookstove design,
not only for the
people in Darfur,
but for the other three billion
people around the world.
That might seem daunting, but
for Danny, it's motivation.
DANIEL WILSON: The
problem is so large,
it has a very large
potential impact.
I can see how the decisions
that I'm making as a designer
are influencing people's lives.
And it just gives me
energy and excitement
just to keep on going.
INTERVIEWER: Danny
isn't the only one
trying to solve global health
problems at the University
of California Berkeley.
Watch this episode to see
how researchers can transform
a cell phone into a
portable microscope that
can diagnose parasitic diseases
like malaria in just 30
seconds.
We want to take a moment
to thank our partner,
the Blum Center for
Developing Economies
at the University of California
Berkeley, an innovation
and research hub that's tackling
issues in global poverty.
Make sure to check out some
of their incredible work
by visiting
blumcenter.berkeley.edu.
Thanks for watching,
and please don't
forget to subscribe
to "Seeker Stories".